hey youtubers is Charlie so the season 4
finale is tonight and it's called the
children so I thought it'd be fun to do
a bonus video about the children of the
forest
obviously the finale is going to be
about a lot of different children you
know Lannister children stark children
mostly the people we've been watching
all season but the children of the
forest is a really big group of people
that the show has only mentioned but not
shown us yet
real quick shout out to all the new
people hello if you're just finding me
for the first time I do weekly Game of
Thrones videos be sure to subscribe to
get everything
I know this week is the finale but
there's a lot of exciting Song of Ice
and Fire stuff happening later this year
so I'll be doing a bunch of bonus videos
I'll explain that later in my episode 10
video tonight though until then let's
start this video with the history lesson
from maester Luwin may he rest in peace
the first time we heard about the
children of the forest was during the
first book and season one went bran was
listening to stories from old man and
maester Luwin I've always been a fan of
the way george RR martin gives us
history lessons using the oral tradition
just like it would have been done in the
real world before literacy and book
printing became really common fun fact
in real life about 10% of the world is
still illiterate it's a really
depressing figure but those people
depend a lot on the oral tradition of
passing down history the same way people
in the Song of Ice and Fire do what are
the children though the best way I can
think to describe them as being like
Aboriginal Westerosi they were the very
first people to inhabit Westeros they
didn't call it Westeros at the time but
it wasn't till about 12,000 years ago
that they made first contact with the
first men until that time they had lived
in symbiosis with the land but then they
signed a pact with the first men to end
their war and the first men basically
took the land that would now become
modern-day Westeros and the children
took to the forest which is kind of
where their name came from children of
the forest so they never really called
themselves children of the forest it's
just like the wildlings not thinking of
themselves as wildlings it's just
someone else's term for describing them
so let's talk a little bit about their
culture no one really understands the
language they spoke but they describe it
as being very musical like music was a
big part of their culture so naturally
their language kind of evolved from
music they hunted in groups and use
weapons and implements the way real-life
Aboriginal people did with a similar
social structure they didn't have kings
or queens they lived in groups in caves
and trees and just all over the land
they were also the ones that started
fashioning tools and weapons out of
obsidian that's what that dragonglass
dagger was made of that we saw
samwell used to kill the white Walker
dragonglass is just another name for
obsidian when maester Luwin was telling
stories to brand he said that the
children have been dead for about a
thousand years and the only thing we
have left to remember them as a visual
reminder is the faces on the weirwood
trees like this face here when bran
first had his vision of the great
weirwood tree it's believed that the
children are the ones that carve those
faces on the trees they didn't just
spontaneously grow whenever the trees
grew I think it's interesting that
maester Luwin says that the children of
the forest have been dead for a thousand
years when a lot of characters on the
show would not stop talking about how
dragons were dead right up to that
season one finale that's one of my
favorite things about the show in the
books it makes you feel like sometimes
the characters are unreliable narrators
like when we're in a POV chapter or a
character on the show is telling a story
they believe what they're saying is true
even if they might have it wrong
dragons being the best example even as
recently as a couple of episodes ago
when Serge or ran afoul of Tywin
Lannister it seemed like there were
people on the smell Council that still
did not believe Daenerys dragons were
real although I think that Tywin does
believe they're real so anytime you hear
a legend or a prophecy like children of
the forest on the show it might just be
true historically there are a couple
really big earth changing events that
the children are associated with most
notably the long night but they're also
associated with the shattering of the
arm of Dorne you know basically breaking
the big land bridge that connected
Westeros with Essos I remember the first
time I heard that all I could think
about was the Isthmus of Panama it was a
real-life land bridge that allowed a
bunch of animals to travel back and
forth between North and South America
during the Eocene era that was like 56
million years ago in real life in our
world in the real world they've been all
kinds of land bridges that have
connected like Asia North America that
have come and gone as sea levels changed
with in Westeros and Game of Thrones
George R Martin just uses magic and war
to get rid of his land bridge about four
thousand years after their war with the
first men ended the White Walkers
invaded that was the beginning of the
long night based on the way the
literature has portrayed the children in
the White Walkers I choose to think of
them as the most important two sides of
the fire and ice' coin it can't be a
complete coincidence that the children
of the force originated the only weapon
that's known to kill White Walkers you
know the obsidian daggers we know more
about the magic of the White Walkers
than the children but as the story
unfolds I think we'll learn that there
are a lot
our similarities between those two races
based on old man stories the last hero
the hero of the long night in all the
big legends and tales was only able to
defeat the white walkers with the help
of the children of the forest so
whichever way the story chooses to bring
them back I think this is going to be
really really important I should also
say that just like a lot of historical
events like the conquering of Westeros
the long night probably did not end with
a single battle it probably took many
many years to end it the best
information we have about the magic of
the children of the force is that it
mostly revolves around greensight that's
the ability to see prophetic dreams on
the show Jojen said that green dreams
always come true but it's possible that
they could also be subject to
interpretation or like in the case of
Daenerys and Mel Sandra's visions they
could be seeing things that may have
happened in an alternate timeline
there's still so much that we don't know
about their power as well as the power
of the White Walkers so I'm pretty sure
that George our Martin is going to
unveil that in the forthcoming books and
obviously the show is probably going to
do it too because it goes way deeper
than necromancy and prophetic dreams
I don't think next year on the show is
going to completely explain all that
stuff but I'll talk about that during my
season 5 predictions video so let's talk
more about the weirwoods because their
power is closely associated with
greenside and the children of the forest
during season 4 bran has had a lot of
visions of the great weirwood in the
north maester Luwin told him that
supposedly the faces on those trees
allow the children to see things
wherever there are other weirwoods with
faces it reminds me a lot of Professor X
inside cerebro it just gives him the
ability to see all over the world
Stannis Baratheon story is a good
example of some weaknesses in that power
though there used to be where woods and
all the castles of Westeros like the
heart tree and the gods would at
Winterfell
but when Stannis became a follower of
the red God he burned his tree as a
symbolic way of casting out the old gods
and letting in a new one so obviously if
anyone was able to see through the
phases and weirwoods they would not be
able to see at Dragonstone anymore and I
don't want to imply that the red God is
a newer God than the old gods the
literature isn't really clear about
whether deities actually exist or if
magic comes from some other place or if
they all exist which God originated the
other gods and a lot of you guys have
commented about your theories of how
some of the gods might be the same God
like different aspects of the same God
it's like saying the Christian God and
the Muslim God are the same God and
those religions just choose to interpret
that differently I don't think that's
completely
I do think there are separate gods on
Game of Thrones but I do believe that a
lot of the smaller prophecies are
different parts of a larger prophecy so
without talking too much about tonight's
episode I really hope we get a teaser
for the children of the forest the
trailer for episode 10 kind of makes it
seem like we're traveling to this tree
like we'll actually physically travel to
it based on the amount of book material
the show has done this season there's
still a lot of books four and five to do
next year so when I post my finale video
tonight I'll add chapter references in
case you guys want to cross-reference
stuff in the books just to see how far
the show is gone as a side tangent if
you guys want to learn more about green
site in green seers I did a bloodraven
bonus video a couple weeks ago so I had
a link to that in the description but
now it's your guy's turn let me know how
do you think that the White Walkers and
the children of the forest are connected
you know are they ancient enemies or are
they just two different groups of
magical creatures that have absolutely
nothing to do with each other I'll be
posting my finale video after the
episode airs tonight be sure to
subscribe to get it
also have more details about the
giveaway whenever I post that you can
actually click here to watch it a lot of
the annotation as soon as I post it and
you can click here to get my season 5
predictions video I'm going to be
posting that on Monday thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
be sure to get ready high fives
you